This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in March, Netflix picked up a long-running Japanese TV program based on a children's book from the 1970s. On Netflix, the show is called Old Enough, but the name of the original Japanese program translates to My First Errant, because in each episode, a child runs an errand for the very first time. Episodes are only 10 to 20 minutes long, but in that short time, a toddler treats the audience to a bite-sized hero's journey, while wearing adorable, tiny sneakers. Bye-bye, bye, bye, jumping in the net.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年三月，Netflix上线了一档基于70年代儿童读物的长寿日本电视节目。在Netflix上，该节目名为《初次跑腿》，但原版日本节目的名字翻译过来是“我的第一次跑腿”，因为在每一集中，孩子都要第一次独自去完成一项任务。每集只有10到20分钟，但在那短短的时间里，一个蹒跚学步的孩子穿着可爱的小运动鞋，为观众呈现了一场微缩版的英雄之旅。再见，再见，跳进网里。
In the first episode, a two and a half-year-old named Heroki is sent to pick up curry and flowers and fish cakes at a market that's a kilometer away. He stumbles down the street by himself. He passes lots of people, even a cop, but they pay him no mind. And then he makes it to the store where a kind clerk helps him find some chrisaathamoms Then as Roki is leaving the shop the dramatic climax of the episode
在第一集中，一个两岁半名叫浩树的孩子被派去一公里外的市场买咖喱、花和鱼饼。他独自摇摇晃晃地走在街上。他经过了许多人，甚至还有一名警察，但他们都没在意他。然后他到达了商店，一位好心的店员帮他找到了一些菊花。接着，当浩树离开商店时，这一集戏剧性的高潮出现了。
He realizes that he has forgotten the curry and he has to go back forgotten the curry. He has to go back. But he eventually finds the curry, completes his quest, and makes the long trek home to his proud parents, dragging the flowers along the ground with boogers streaming down his face. When old enough debuted on Netflix, it was a hit. That's Slate Reporter Henry Cabar. American audiences couldn't get enough of these very cute kids and their very grown-up tasks. But there was another element drawing people to the show.
他意识到自己忘了买咖喱，不得不折回去。他忘了咖喱，他必须回去。但他最终找到了咖喱，完成了任务，拖着花，挂着鼻涕，长途跋涉回到骄傲的父母身边。《初次跑腿》在Netflix上线后大受欢迎。这是Slate的记者亨利·卡巴尔。美国观众对这些非常可爱、执行着非常成人化任务的孩子们着迷不已。但还有另一个因素吸引着人们观看这个节目。
A sense of disbelief. Who in their right mind would send a two-year-old kid out into the world like this? What's to stop them from getting kidnapped? Or hit by a car. One that FUX viewer tweeted, do this in the US and the child will never be seen again. You know, you guys know me. I mean, I raised my kids in bubbles. I protected them and I put up some guardrails,
一种难以置信的感觉。谁会脑子进水让一个两岁的孩子这样独自走进世界？什么能阻止他们被绑架？或者被车撞？一位福克斯观众发推文说，在美国这样做，孩子就再也找不到了。你们知道，你们了解我。我的意思是，我是在温室里抚养我的孩子的。我保护他们，并设置了一些护栏。
but I would not do this. My first errand is a gimmicky show with Hoki music and a laugh track. But it's also rooted in a truth about Japanese society. Most Japanese children are remarkably independent from a very young age, way more independent than kids in the US. In Japanese cities, fifth graders make 85% of their weekday trips without a parent.
但我不会这样做。《初次跑腿》是一档带有滑稽音乐和罐头笑声的噱头节目。但它也植根于日本社会的一个事实。大多数日本孩子从很小的时候起就非常独立，比美国的孩子独立得多。在日本的城市里，五年级的学生有85%的平日出行是不需要父母陪同的。
And this remarkable child mobility is made possible by everything from the neighbor's next door to the width of the streets. It's important to note that my first errand is reality TV. Like all reality TV, it's not real, at least not completely. The kids on the show aren't actually alone. There are producers following them every step of the way, hiding behind trash cans or pretending to be cab drivers. And on the show, the kids are attempting their first errand at a much younger age than they would be in real life. Like, they wouldn't necessarily be, I mean, going out as a two-year-old, you know, if there
这种非凡的儿童出行能力得益于从邻居到街道宽度等方方面面。需要注意的是，《初次跑腿》是真人秀。像所有真人秀一样，它不是真实的，至少不完全是。节目中的孩子实际上并不是孤身一人。有制作人员全程跟随，躲在垃圾桶后面或假装成出租车司机。而且在节目中，孩子们尝试第一次跑腿的年龄比现实生活中要小得多。比如，他们不一定非要，我的意思是，作为一个两岁的孩子，你知道，如果周围有摄制组的话，
was a camera crew around, and that's kind of, for the TV show, they kind of, you know, make it a little bit more extreme. But the whole idea of kids going out when they're five or six and, you know, getting whatever, some diapers for their little brother, that's not dramatized. Michi Weighgood was born in Japan, lived in New Jersey as a kid, and then moved back to Osaka at 13. She totally gets why the show has become such a hit both in Japan and in the US. I mean, the kids are really, really cute.
那对电视节目来说，他们有点，你知道，让它变得更极端了。但孩子们在五六岁时出门，你知道，为弟弟买尿布之类的想法，那并不是戏剧化的。道智·韦古德在日本出生，小时候住在新泽西州，13岁时搬回大阪。她完全明白为什么这个节目在日本和美国都如此受欢迎。我的意思是，孩子们真的非常非常可爱。
That's one. But also the whole overcoming adversity, like some of the most popular shows are the ones where the kid has some sort of mishap. Like the one where the girl, for hours is trying to get a cabbage out of the ground. That's Michi's husband Owen Waygood, describing an episode set in the country
这是一个原因。但还有克服逆境的过程，比如一些最受欢迎的节目是孩子遇到某种小事故的那些。比如那个女孩花了几个小时试图把卷心菜从地里拔出来的片段。那是道智的丈夫欧文·韦古德，描述在乡村拍摄的一集。
where a young girl struggles to harvest a cabbage from the family vegetable patch. And that kind of view into the child's life as she's like walking away going, oh, mom's gonna be like, what took you so long? Are you coming home when it's getting dark? Both Michi and Owen have unique perspectives on my first errand. Michi because she grew up between Japan and the US, and Owen, because he basically studies exactly what the show is all about. So my PST topic was basically examining why children in Japan are able to get around by themselves.
一个小女孩努力从家庭菜园里收获卷心菜。那种观察孩子生活的视角，当她走开时说，哦，妈妈会说，你怎么花了这么长时间？天黑了你还没回家吗？道智和欧文对《初次跑腿》都有独特的视角。道智是因为她在日本和美国之间长大，而欧文是因为他研究的正是这个节目所展示的内容。所以我的博士课题基本上是研究为什么日本的孩子能够独自出行。
Owen is the professor at Polytechnic Montreal, but he did his doctoral thesis at Kyoto University. Just living there, you noticed things that are different and one of the differences was that you saw kids getting around, you saw kids playing together in the park, you saw them on the subway. And so Owen started researching children's mobility. And he collaborated with Ayako Tanaguchi,
欧文是蒙特利尔理工学院的教授，但他是在京都大学完成的博士论文。住在那里，你会注意到一些不同的事情，其中一个区别就是你看到孩子们四处走动，看到孩子们在公园里一起玩耍，看到他们乘坐地铁。于是欧文开始研究儿童的出行能力。他与筑波大学的工程学教授谷口绫子进行了合作。
a professor of engineering at the University of Tsukuba. She remembers the first time she let her son go out solo. Professor Tanaguchi says she didn't let her son travel alone until he was in first grade because he was absent-minded, a bit of a space cadet. And when he did walk to school for the first time, she followed her distance, and sure enough, he got sidetracked. She saw him picking up bugs and chasing butterflies. Professor Tenniguchi thinks there are a few different cultural factors
她记得第一次让儿子独自出门的情景。谷口教授说，直到儿子上一年级她才让他独自出行，因为他心不在焉，有点像个“太空人”。当他第一次走路去学校时，她保持距离跟着他，果然，他分心了。她看到他捡虫子、追蝴蝶。谷口教授认为有几个不同的文化因素。
that make the tradition of first-errant possible. First, she says, is an environment where everyone in the neighborhood feels responsible for the local children. They may not have TV producers following them, but when a child is walking by themselves to a quarter-sour in Japan, they're not really alone either. She says that in Japan, there's a culture of communities raising children collectively. And that communal culture is maintained in part through neighborhood associations. Everyone within a given area will pay monthly dues of around two to five dollars. Then the association will organize festivals and activities and help people get to know each other.
使得“第一次跑腿”的传统成为可能。她说，首先是一个邻里间每个人都对当地孩子感到负责的环境。他们可能没有电视制作人跟着，但当一个日本孩子独自走向便利店时，他们也不是真的孤身一人。她说，在日本，有一种社区共同抚养孩子的文化。这种社区文化部分是通过邻里协会来维持的。特定区域内的每个人都会支付每月约两到五美元的会费。然后协会会组织节日和活动，帮助人们互相认识。
Japan's low crime rates bolster parents' confidence, but local PTAs also map safe routes through neighborhoods and ask retirees to keep an eye out when kids are going to and from school. This tight-knit sense of community isn't just present in small towns in the countryside. In his research, Owen found that contrary to Western stereotypes, neighborhoods in Japanese cities are even more communal than small towns, and that actually the more urban a kid was, the more likely they were to know people in their neighborhood.
日本的低犯罪率增强了父母的信心，但当地的家长教师协会（PTA）也会绘制社区内的安全路线，并要求退休人员在孩子们上下学时留意。这种紧密的社区意识不仅存在于乡村小镇。在研究中，欧文发现与西方刻板印象相反，日本城市的社区甚至比小镇更具社区感，而且实际上孩子居住的城市化程度越高，他们就越有可能认识邻居。
And there have been international studies that show that parents in Japan are the most likely to say that they know people that will help their children if need be. And it increases as you go more urban. A culture is only part of the story. The biggest reason why children in Japan are able to move around more freely is the way the country has designed its streets and neighborhoods. There is an expectation in Japan that children can get around by themselves. And so if you have a cultural expectation that children can go places by themselves, you're going to build a cultural expectation that the children can go places by themselves,
有国际研究表明，日本的父母最有可能表示他们认识在必要时会帮助他们孩子的人。而且随着城市化程度的提高，这种比例还会增加。文化只是故事的一部分。日本孩子能够更自由地四处走动的最大原因是该国设计街道和社区的方式。日本有一种期望，即孩子可以独自四处走动。因此，如果你有一种文化期望，即孩子可以独自去任何地方，你就会建立一种文化期望，即孩子可以独自去任何地方，
you're going to build a built environment that facilitates that. And there are actually really specific aspects of that built environment that help children get around independently in Japan, starting with zoning. In the US and Canada, cities are usually divided up into distinct zones.
你就会建立一个促进这种行为的建筑环境。在日本，确实有一些非常具体的建筑环境方面有助于孩子独立出行，首先是分区规划。在美国和加拿大，城市通常被划分为不同的区域。
You have a residential zone and a commercial zone. And if you want to go shopping or go to work, you have to travel between them. Which often requires a car. But that's not true in Japan. There's no zone that says you can only have residential buildings here. So the strictest zoning, you can have some apartments and you can have some small businesses and things like this. You can have a small office in the residential zone and that type of development means that there are destinations within walking distance. You are much more likely to find a shop or a grocery store
你有住宅区和商业区。如果你想去购物或上班，你必须在它们之间穿梭。这通常需要开车。但在日本并非如此。没有规定说这里只能有住宅楼的分区。所以即使在最严格的分区里，你也可以有一些公寓，也可以有一些小企业之类的。你可以在住宅区有一个小办公室，这种开发意味着目的地都在步行距离之内。你更有可能找到一家商店或杂货店。
that's just a short walk from a kid's house. The most important destination for children is of course school. Early on in his research, Owen went to an elementary school. I met the principal and I explained, I'm all I'm looking at how children get around in Japan and I asked him, so how do children get to school? And he said, he kind of looked at me on and he said,
离孩子的家只有很短的步行路程。对孩子来说最重要的目的地当然是学校。在研究初期，欧文去了一所小学。我见到了校长，我解释说，我正在研究日本的孩子是如何出行的，我问他，那么孩子们是如何去学校的？他说，他有点看着我，然后说，
well, they walk almost in the... How else would they get to school? Like, this is how children get around. It's they can walk. In the United States, only about 10% of kids walk to school. In Japan, the number is more like 80%. And that's possible because of a second design decision. In Japan, elementary schools are often built right in the center of neighborhoods. An ironic part is that they took an idea from the US that said the elementary school should be
嗯，他们几乎都是走路……不然他们怎么去学校呢？就像，这就是孩子们出行的方式。他们可以走路。在美国，只有大约10%的孩子走路去学校。在日本，这个数字更接近80%。这之所以可能，是因为第二个设计决策。在日本，小学通常建在社区的中心。讽刺的是，他们借鉴了一个来自美国的想法，即小学应该是。
the heart of a neighborhood. In 1929, an American planner named Clarence Perry famously outlined this idea, the school at the center of a neighborhood unit. So, in terms of design, so if you have the elementary school at the center of your neighborhood, it shortens the distance for everyone. After the Second World War, Japanese planners took inspiration from Perry as they rebuilt their cities. And so, Japanese laws
社区的心脏。1929年，一位名叫克拉伦斯·佩里的美国规划师提出了这个著名的想法，即学校位于社区单元的中心。所以，在设计方面，如果你把小学放在社区中心，它就缩短了每个人的距离。第二次世界大战后，日本规划师在重建城市时从佩里那里获得了灵感。所以，日本法律。
says that no child should have to go more than two and a half miles to get to elementary school, and the distance is often much less. But it's not just the distance is often much less. But it's not just the distance between home and school that determines whether kids can safely make the walk. There's also another urban design factor, the size of the streets. The United States has really wide streets, even in residential neighborhoods. These days, streets are often designed to be wide enough to give fire engines room to maneuver. But as car traffic has increased,
规定没有孩子应该为了上小学而走超过两英里半的路程，而且距离通常要短得多。但不仅仅是距离。不仅仅是家和学校之间的距离决定了孩子是否能安全地走完这段路。还有另一个城市设计因素，即街道的宽度。美国有非常宽的街道，即使在住宅区也是如此。如今，街道的设计通常足够宽，以便给消防车留出机动空间。但随着汽车交通的增加，
those wide streets have encouraged fast driving and turned the walk to school into a dangerous obstacle course, even for kids who live close by. So you ended up with actually this, it was like a Frankenstein, like neighborhoods, where the neighborhood was intended to be built for families and children,
那些宽阔的街道鼓励了快速驾驶，并将上学之路变成了一个危险的障碍赛，即使是对住在附近的孩子来说也是如此。所以你最终得到的是，这就像一个弗兰肯斯坦，就像社区，社区本意是为家庭和孩子建造的，
but then it actually ended up just being really dangerous for kids to get around. But in Japan, residential streets are much narrower. Interestingly, one reason why is that unlike the US, horse-drawn carriages never became common on Japanese streets in the era before the automobile. And without carriage traffic, streets just didn't need to be that wide. And so, like that historic part leads to streets that are much narrower, and if you have narrow streets that naturally slow down vehicles. Satoshi Nakawa is an engineering professor at Kyoto University. He's doing research on the
但实际上它最终对孩子们的出行来说非常危险。但在日本，住宅街道要窄得多。有趣的是，原因之一是与美国不同，马车在汽车时代之前的日本街道上从未普及。没有马车交通，街道就不需要那么宽。所以，历史原因导致街道窄得多，如果你有狭窄的街道，它们自然会减慢车辆的速度。中川聪是京都大学的工程学教授。他正在研究。
history of traffic accidents in Japan. Professor Nikko says that traditionally, Japanese cities didn't have large plazas. And so these narrow streets were the key public spaces where people went shopping, got to know each other, and let their kids play. At this point in our conversation, he actually picked up his laptop, and we were talking on Zoom, and walked over to his window to show me the street outside. It couldn't have been more than 20 feet across. Instead of building streets to fit the turning radius of a fire engine, like we do in the US, Japan just built smaller fire engines.
日本交通事故的历史。中川教授说，传统上，日本城市没有大型广场。所以这些狭窄的街道是人们购物、互相认识、让孩子玩耍的关键公共空间。在谈话的这一点上，他实际上拿起了他的笔记本电脑，我们在Zoom上交谈，走到窗前向我展示外面的街道。它宽不过20英尺。日本没有像我们在美国那样建造符合消防车转弯半径的街道，而是建造了更小的消防车。
The next major design feature that makes Japanese streets safer for kids is pretty counterintuitive. The first day I was in Japan, and I was walking on one of these streets without a sidewalk. So as a North American, in my head, I'm like, I'm in a dangerous situation because there's no sidewalk. And as the cars were coming up behind me, I kept on kind of jumping up against the wall because like my North American brain said, you need to get out of the way of the car. But I was watching everyone else, all these old ladies and children walking along
使日本街道对孩子更安全的下一个主要设计特点非常反直觉。我在日本的第一天，走在这些没有人行道的街道上。作为一个北美洲人，我心里想，我处于危险之中，因为没有人行道。当汽车从我身后驶来时，我不断地跳向墙边，因为我的北美大脑告诉我，你需要避开汽车。但我观察其他人，所有这些老太太和孩子们走着。
without a care in the world. And I kind of started noticing that, oh, the cars pay attention to the pedestrians, and it's the cars that move out of the way for them. In fact, one thing that sidewalks do more to benefit cars than they do pedestrians. It's getting the pedestrian out of the way, allowing those cars to go high speed,
无忧无虑。我开始注意到，哦，汽车会注意行人，是汽车在为他们避让。事实上，人行道对汽车的好处比对行人的好处更多。它让行人避开，允许汽车高速行驶，
and then you have fatal collisions at intersections. So the starting point of the whole transportation planning is different. Like, are you simply planning to move cars or are you planning for people of any age to be able to do the things that they need to do in their life? Japan does have wider arterial roads where traffic can move fast. Those roads usually do have sidewalks and stoplights and crosswalks. But inside of neighborhoods, what you'll mostly see are what sometimes get called living streets.
然后在十字路口发生致命碰撞。所以整个交通规划的出发点是不同的。你是仅仅计划移动汽车，还是计划让任何年龄的人都能做他们生活中需要做的事情？日本确实有更宽的干道，交通可以快速移动。这些道路通常有人行道、红绿灯和人行横道。但在社区内部，你主要看到的是有时被称为“生活街道”的东西。
So if you are in a neighborhood, whether it's Tokyo or Kyoto or wherever, that residential street, you'll just see people hanging out, chatting, talking, using that space as a public space. And that is made possible by yet another urban design feature that gives these streets their distinctive feel. Something even stranger to North Americans than no sidewalks. No parking. Japan doesn't allow overnight street parking. In fact, you cannot buy a car in Japan unless you have an off-street parking space.
所以如果你在一个社区，无论是东京还是京都或其他地方，那条住宅街道，你只会看到人们在闲逛、聊天、谈话，把那个空间当作公共空间使用。这得益于另一个赋予这些街道独特感觉的城市设计特征。这对北美洲人来说比没有人行道更奇怪的事情。没有停车位。日本不允许过夜路边停车。事实上，除非你有非路边停车位，否则你在日本买不到车。
Because cars are considered private property that shouldn't be stored in an important public space. Those parking rules have contributed to Japan's low rate of urban car ownership and excellent public transit, but they have also made the streets safer. Without a wall of parked cars, drivers have a clear view of the whole street and can more easily spot a little kid who's about to cross. The street is also seen as a valuable public space that deserves our care and attention. Here's Michi Weigut again. Like the guy in our neighborhood in Kyoto who would come out like every morning and wash the area in front of his shop. It's common practice in Japan, especially elderly people do it, but they come and they actually wash down the part of the road that is in front of their shop or home. They really take pride and I guess responsibility for that section, so it's really not seen as a space
因为汽车被认为是私人财产，不应该存放在重要的公共空间。这些停车规则促成了日本较低的城市汽车拥有率和优秀的公共交通，但也使街道更安全。没有一排排停放的汽车，司机对整条街道有清晰的视野，更容易发现即将过马路的小孩。街道也被视为值得我们关心和关注的宝贵公共空间。这是道智·韦古德。就像我们京都社区里的那个人，他每天早上都会出来清洗他店前的区域。这在日本很常见，尤其是老年人这样做，他们会清洗店前或家前的路面。他们真的引以为豪，我想是对那部分区域负责，所以它真的不被视为。
for cars to pass by. It's part of their neighborhood, part of their home. The downstream effect of all this urban planning stuff, that mixed-use zoning, the nearby schools, the narrow streets, the lack of sidewalks, the off-street parking, it is all conspired to make Japan a pretty great place for kids to get around independently. Although independence doesn't necessarily mean
汽车经过的空间。它是他们社区的一部分，他们家的一部分。所有这些城市规划东西的下游效应，混合用途分区、附近的学校、狭窄的街道、没有人行道、非路边停车，所有这些都促使日本成为一个非常适合孩子独立出行的地方。虽然独立并不一定意味着。
that they're always traveling alone, to make sure that even the smallest, most absent-minded kids can get to school on foot, Japan has implemented one of the world's most adorable transportation innovations, the walking school bus, Shudan Toko. In a walking school bus, older kids pick up younger ones as the whole group makes its way into school. Each bus might cover a single apartment building or a few blocks of houses. The leader carries a yellow flag,
他们总是独自旅行，为了确保即使是最小、最心不在焉的孩子也能步行上学，日本实施了世界上最可爱的交通创新之一，步行校车，即“集团登校”。在步行校车中，大孩子在整个小组前往学校时接上小孩子。每辆“校车”可能覆盖一栋公寓楼或几个街区的房屋。领队拿着一面黄旗，
sometimes kids wear yellow hats. There's a sense of safety in numbers, and it's also just fun for the kids. Owen and Ico wrote about this practice a few years ago. Each family is sent information about when they need to have their child ready to get picked up by the walking school bus. So you have to have your child at your front door
有时孩子们戴着黄帽子。人多有一种安全感，对孩子们来说也很有趣。欧文和绫子几年前写过这种做法。每个家庭都会收到关于他们需要让孩子准备好被步行校车接走的时间的信息。所以你必须让你的孩子在你的前门。
ready to meet up with the other children from your small neighborhood who are going to walk together to school. And it's going to be children, so it's going to be the great fives and great six. They're leading that group. And it's considered part of the school day. Across Japan, walking to school isn't just an option.
准备好与其他来自你小社区的孩子会合，他们将一起步行去学校。而且会是孩子们，所以会是五年级和六年级的学生。他们在带领那个小组。这被认为是学校生活的一部分。在日本各地，步行上学不仅仅是一个选择。
It's a given. Although Owen said that that principle that he talked with sometimes made exceptions. He's like, oh, well occasionally, if a child has broken their leg, we let their parents bring them by a car. But he's like, but the cars are generally forbidden. And again, it's like, okay, why the cars,
这是一个既定事实。虽然欧文说他交谈过的那位校长有时会破例。他说，哦，偶尔，如果一个孩子摔断了腿，我们允许他们的父母用车送他们。但他又说，但汽车通常是被禁止的。再一次，就像，好吧，为什么汽车，
like the parents can't bring the children by car? And again, he looked at me kind of in that, this is a stupid question. He's like, yes, of course, because the cars would cause danger for the other children. Japanese people sometimes take these systems for granted, but they didn't just happen. The walking school bus took off in the 1960s and 70s.
父母不能用车送孩子吗？再一次，他看着我，带着那种“这是一个愚蠢的问题”的表情。他说，是的，当然，因为汽车会对其他孩子造成危险。日本人有时认为这些系统是理所当然的，但它们并非偶然发生。步行校车在20世纪60年代和70年代兴起。
At the time, Japan had just become the second largest car producer in the world, and Toyota's, Honda's and Nissan's were on the rise on Japanese roads. Here's Satoshi Nakau again. He says that in 1970, Japan had a record high number of traffic fatalities. There were almost 17,000 car-related deaths. But there were also widespread environmental protests, often led by mothers concerned about the dangers of cars and car pollution. And so Japan came up with some new policies, including one that's still in place today.
当时，日本刚刚成为世界上第二大汽车生产国，丰田、本田和尼桑在日本道路上崛起。这是中川聪。他说，1970年，日本的交通死亡人数创下历史新高。有近17,000人死于汽车相关事故。但也有广泛的环境抗议，通常由担心汽车危险和汽车污染的母亲领导。所以日本提出了一些新政策，包括今天仍在实施的一项。
Baning car traffic around elementary schools when kids are arriving in the morning. The roads got safer, and Japan's tradition of walking to school was able to continue. To North American eyes, Japan remains a utopia of free-range kids. Going up between Osaka and New Jersey, Michiwega felt this difference profoundly.
在孩子们早上到达时禁止小学周围的汽车交通。道路变得更安全了，日本步行上学的传统得以延续。在北美人的眼中，日本仍然是一个自由放养孩子的乌托邦。在大阪和新泽西之间长大，道智·韦古德深刻地感受到了这种差异。
So when I was growing up in the States from 4 to 13, I was in suburban New Jersey. So the only place really that I could walk to was the public library down the street. Oh no, and then there was one strip mall as well that I could get to. But that was about it, like that was the extent to of our freedom.
所以当我在美国从4岁长到13岁时，我住在新泽西州的郊区。所以我唯一能走到的地方就是街尽头的公共图书馆。哦不，还有一个我可以去的小型购物中心。但仅此而已，这就是我们自由的极限。
But when Michi's family moved back to Asaka, she and her friends would walk everywhere, or get on their bikes and take off, go shopping, hang out in the park or in the rice patties in your school. And I don't think I really realized how special that was growing up just because it was, it just kind of seemed normal to me. I'm like, oh, that's what we do in Japan,
但当道智的家人搬回大阪时，她和她的朋友们会到处走，或者骑上自行车出发，去购物，在公园里闲逛，或者在学校的稻田里玩耍。我不认为我在成长过程中真正意识到这有多特别，只是因为它看起来很正常。我想，哦，这就是我们在日本做的事情，
and this is what we do in the States. And it wasn't until I was older that I realized, oh, actually, it's not a given. Today, Michi and Owen Waygood do not live in Japan. They're raising their family in Quebec. But they still wanted their three kids to do a first errand. The idea of our kids being independent has is really really important to both of us and because we
这就是我们在美国做的事情。直到我长大后，我才意识到，哦，实际上，这不是理所当然的。今天，道智和欧文·韦古德不住在日本。他们在魁北克抚养他们的家庭。但他们仍然希望他们的三个孩子进行第一次跑腿。让我们的孩子独立的想法对我们俩来说都非常非常重要，因为我们。
You know, we spent a lot of time in Japan and have observed happy independent kids doing this sort of thing all the time. We decided that you know It's something that we really want to instill in our kids too all the time, we decided that, you know, it's something that we really want to instill in our kids too. Coming up after the break, the way good kids do a first errand in Canada. I felt stressed, nervous, but when I did it, it wasn't that hard. So the way goods have moved to Canada, but they still wanted their children to do a first errand. I wanted to get the kids' perspective on all this, so we gave the mic to Maira and Toma. So I'm Maira Wigid and I'm 13 years old.
你知道，我们在日本花了很多时间，观察到快乐、独立的孩子一直在做这种事情。我们决定，你知道，这是我们真的想灌输给孩子的东西。休息后，韦古德家的孩子们在加拿大进行第一次跑腿。我感到压力、紧张，但当我做的时候，并没有那么难。所以韦古德一家搬到了加拿大，但他们仍然希望他们的孩子进行第一次跑腿。我想听听孩子们对这一切的看法，所以我们把麦克风给了迈拉和托马。我是迈拉·韦古德，我13岁。
I'm Toma Wigid and I'm 13 years old. I'm Toma, we good, and I'm nine years old. Mira and Toma grew up watching my first errand on YouTube before the show was released on Netflix. They used it to practice their Japanese. Sometimes the episodes can be kind of funny though when they are like lost and are like, oh no, what do I do? But they always end up finding their way.
我是托马·韦古德，我13岁。我是托马·韦古德，我9岁。迈拉和托马在节目在Netflix发布之前就在YouTube上观看《初次跑腿》。他们用它来练习日语。有时这些剧集可能有点好笑，当他们迷路时，会说，哦不，我该怎么办？但他们最终总是能找到路。
If they wouldn't find their way back, I don't think they would put it on Netflix. Hahaha. Maira and Toma each did their first errand a bit later than the kids on the show. I was like six. It was in Quebec City, and I just remember being excited
如果他们找不到回家的路，我想他们不会把它放在Netflix上。哈哈。迈拉和托马进行第一次跑腿的时间都比节目中的孩子晚一些。我当时大概六岁。那是在魁北克市，我只记得很兴奋。
because we're going to get like Japanese rice cakes, Mouchi, which was a treat to us all. I'm like, oh, yeah, we can get a treat. Toma also did his first errand when he was six, but where the family lives now. In Montreal, he was supposed to go to the store and get ingredients for dinner. His parents were feeling a little nervous because Toma does not have a great sense of direction and so Owen decided to draw him a map. But I was still like, what if I go the wrong way?
因为我们要去买日本米糕，麻糬，这对我们所有人来说都是一种享受。我想，哦，是的，我们可以得到一种享受。托马也在六岁时进行了第一次跑腿，但在他们现在住的地方。在蒙特利尔，他应该去商店买晚餐的配料。他的父母感到有点紧张，因为托马的方向感不是很好，所以欧文决定给他画一张地图。但我还是想，如果我走错路了怎么办？
And then they miss it and I get lost forever. You know, had him go over it over and over again, how he was going to get there, what he's going to do, what he's going to do when he crosses our little residential street. And then he took off, but I was really nervous about this one, so I tagged him the whole way. Michi followed Toma at a distance, keeping out of sight by ducking behind park cars,
然后他们错过了，我永远迷路了。你知道，让他们一遍又一遍地复习，他要怎么去那里，他要做什么，当他穿过我们的小住宅街道时他要做什么。然后他出发了，但我对这次真的很紧张，所以我全程跟着他。道智在远处跟着托马，通过躲在停放的汽车后面保持视线之外，
like a producer on my first errand. They probably looked really suspicious. She watched as he entered the store. One of the ingredients he needed to find was ginger. But the ginger was kind of on a shelf that was too high for him to reach. And so he went in there, I probably couldn't reach it. And then I guess he did some quick problem solving.
就像《初次跑腿》里的制作人一样。他们看起来可能真的很可疑。她看着他走进商店。他需要找到的配料之一是姜。但姜所在的架子对他来说太高了，够不着。所以他进去了，我可能够不着。然后我想他做了一些快速的问题解决。
There was one of the things I couldn't reach, so I had to ask someone. He asked someone that was working there to get the ginger for him. It took me courage, because I was very shy and nervous. But yeah, I did it. I got it. And then I felt proud of myself.
有一件东西我够不着，所以我不得不问别人。他问了一个在那里工作的人帮他拿姜。这需要勇气，因为我很害羞和紧张。但是的，我做到了。我拿到了。然后我为自己感到骄傲。
How did Owen and Michi make this Japanese practice work in Canada, partly through diligent preparation? You know, like another thing that I kind of want understood is that we don't just kick the kids out the door and be like, good luck guys. You know, we really put in the groundwork. We practice with them a lot. You know, we go through different scenarios.
欧文和道智是如何在加拿大实现这种日本做法的？部分是通过勤奋的准备。你知道，我希望理解的另一件事是，我们不仅仅是把孩子踢出门，说，祝你们好运。你知道，我们真的打下了基础。我们和他们练习了很多。你知道，我们经历不同的场景。
If they get lost or if something happens. So by the time that they're ready to go out on their own, they're very, very confident and they feel really good about themselves for doing it. But the most important piece of groundwork was picking the right neighborhood in the first place. We didn't just randomly choose a neighborhood to live in. Does some extent we looked for that neighborhood
如果他们迷路了或者发生了什么事。所以当他们准备好独自出门时，他们非常非常自信，并且因为这样做而对自己感觉很好。但最重要的基础工作是首先选择合适的社区。我们并没有随意选择一个居住的社区。在某种程度上，我们寻找那个社区。
where it would be feasible. And they ended up in a dense and walkable part of town, where most things they need are just a short walk away. So that acted a bit like a Japanese neighborhood in that fashion? In other words, they found a neighborhood that came close to recreating the urbanism they prized in Japan. And that in turn helped them give their kids a Japanese style sense of independence. There's one street in their neighborhood that actually gets closed to cars during the summer.
在那里这是可行的。他们最终来到了镇上一个密集且适合步行的地方，他们需要的大多数东西都在短步行距离内。所以这在某种程度上就像一个日本社区？换句话说，他们找到了一个接近重建他们在日本所珍视的城市主义的社区。这反过来帮助他们给了孩子一种日本式的独立感。他们社区里有一条街道在夏天实际上禁止汽车通行。
It's kind of like a living street in Japan. It's nice because we don't have to really worry about they're being caused there and it's a big space where we can just like get a roller blades or scooters or whatever and just hang around there. And when the kids do travel on streets with lots of traffic, they are extra careful. Especially when it's trucks, because trucks are huge and a lot of the time they can't see me. You make like eye contact with the drivers, like sure they see you. When I was younger, I just put my hand up like that
它有点像日本的生活街道。这很好，因为我们不必担心那里有车，这是一个很大的空间，我们可以像溜冰鞋或滑板车之类的东西，只是在那里闲逛。当孩子们在交通繁忙的街道上旅行时，他们会格外小心。特别是卡车，因为卡车很大，很多时候他们看不到我。你和司机进行眼神交流，确保他们看到你。我小的时候，我只是像那样举起手。
so we can at least see a hand. And it's like, tips your fingers. Yeah. The way goods were able to find a little slice of Japanese urbanism for their kids growing up in Quebec. But the cultural side of children's mobility still isn't there. For me, what bothers me the most is the social eye, like almost the stigma of letting young children go off on their own. The judgment of friends and neighbors can fall especially hard on Mici. She says that mothers in particular are expected to always be hovering and protective of their children. But I definitely, that's something
这样我们至少能看到一只手。就像，指尖。是的。韦古德一家能够在魁北克为他们的孩子找到一小片日本城市主义。但儿童出行的文化方面仍然不存在。对我来说，最困扰我的是社会眼光，几乎是让年幼的孩子独自出门的污名。朋友和邻居的评判对道智来说尤其沉重。她说，母亲尤其被期望总是盘旋在孩子身边并保护他们。但我绝对，那是某件事。
that I had to actively try to ignore, if you will, while doing this for the kids, because I mean, every mother has all these terrible thoughts going through their head all the time, about what might happen to their kids. But, you know, it's really my job to make sure that my kids are well-equipped to live life and, you know, handle's really my job to make sure that my kids are well equipped to live life and, you know, handle obstacles and all that stuff and not for me to be there all the time
我必须积极尝试忽略，如果你愿意的话，在为孩子们做这件事的同时，因为我的意思是，每个母亲脑子里一直都有所有这些可怕的想法，关于孩子可能发生的事情。但是，你知道，确保我的孩子有能力过生活，你知道，处理障碍和所有这些事情，而不是我一直都在那里，这真的是我的工作。
for them. A few years ago, a single father in Vancouver spent two years teaching his kids, ages 7 and 10, how to use the city bus to get to school. Someone complained to the child protection service in British Columbia and the dad was told to stop. He sued the province, lost in court, and finally won on appeal. And he got lucky. In the US, parents can be fined or jailed
对他们来说。几年前，温哥华的一位单身父亲花了两年时间教他7岁和10岁的孩子如何乘坐城市公交车去学校。有人向不列颠哥伦比亚省的儿童保护服务机构投诉，父亲被告知停止。他起诉了该省，在法庭上败诉，最终在上诉中获胜。他很幸运。在美国，父母可能会被罚款或监禁。
for leaving their children alone in public. This is worse for parents of color who are often more harshly scrutinized by neighbors, police, and social workers. In 2014, a South Carolina mom was arrested for letting her nine-year-old play in the park while she worked to shift at a nearby McDonald's. But Michi and Owen say that going against the grain has been worth it for their family. They've watched their kids grow into confident, self-reliant people.
因为把孩子独自留在公共场所。这对有色人种父母来说更糟，他们经常受到邻居、警察和社会工作者的更严厉审查。2014年，南卡罗来纳州的一位母亲因让九岁的孩子在公园玩耍而她去附近的麦当劳轮班而被捕。但道智和欧文说，逆流而上对他们的家庭来说是值得的。他们看着他们的孩子成长为自信、自立的人。
Tom and Miro are a little older now. Miro is 13. She takes the Metro and the bus to school every day. It's a 40-minute commute that she does all by herself. I ask the kids whether they think other parents in the US and Canada should give this a try. Yeah, because it gives kids much more liberty to go around places themselves and they don't always have to wait for the parents. The parents can do their own things more. I feel like if other kids can go out and they don't have to go with them, tell me you have anything to say. Yeah, like they should try it out.
托马和迈拉现在大了一点。迈拉13岁了。她每天独自乘坐地铁和公交车上学。这是一个她独自完成的40分钟通勤。我问孩子们他们是否认为美国和加拿大的其他父母应该尝试一下。是的，因为它给了孩子们更多的自由去自己去地方，他们不必总是等待父母。父母可以更多地做他们自己的事情。我觉得如果其他孩子可以出去，他们不必和他们一起去，托马你有什么要说的吗？是的，他们应该尝试一下。
Like if they're too scared, I understand. If they didn't do this already, they could ask their parents to maybe like make a map, like my parents did. It helped me. And then now when I'm doing it more often, it's much more normal for me. And I'm not really scared anymore. much more normal for me and I'm not really scared anymore. But the truth is, it wasn't the map of the neighborhood that got six-year-old Toma to the store. It was the neighborhood itself, a place with mixed-use zoning, small streets, and low-speed
如果他们太害怕了，我理解。如果他们还没有这样做，他们可以要求他们的父母像我父母那样画一张地图。它帮助了我。现在当我更频繁地这样做时，对我来说更正常了。我不再害怕了。对我来说更正常了，我不再害怕了。但事实是，并不是社区地图让六岁的托马去了商店。是社区本身，一个拥有混合用途分区、小街道和低速限制的地方。
limits. There's also a local park he can easily get to on his own. Most kids aren't so lucky. So much of the built environment in North America has been designed to get grown-ups, in cars, to work, not to help little kids safely walk to school. And so, if we want to give other families the chance to do this, it's going to require us to build our cities with six year olds in mind. ["Mine, The R&B With Six Year Olds in Mind." ["Mine, The R&B With Six Year Olds in Mind." ["Mine, The R&B With Six Year Olds in Mind." ["Mine, The R&B With Six Year Olds in Mind." ["Mine, The R&B
还有一个当地公园，他可以很容易地独自到达。大多数孩子没有那么幸运。北美如此多的建筑环境被设计成让成年人开车去工作，而不是帮助小孩子安全地步行上学。所以，如果我们想给其他家庭机会这样做，就需要我们以六岁孩子为中心来建设我们的城市。
With Six Year Olds in Mind." ["Mine, The R&B With Six Year Olds in Mind." 99% Invisible was produced this week by Henry Crabar, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, and Kelly Prime, Original Music by Swan Rial, Sound Mix and Additional Production by Martin Gonzales, Fact Checking by Graham Haysha. Our Executive Producer is Delaney Hall, Crust Colestet is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Jason D'Alyone,
以六岁孩子为中心。《99%隐形》本周由亨利·克拉巴制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和凯利·普莱姆编辑，原创音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作，声音混音和额外制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。我们的执行制片人是德莱尼·霍尔，克鲁斯特·科莱斯特是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括薇薇安·李、杰森·达里昂、
Christopher Johnson, Chris Baroube, Lashemadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Megumi Yamamoto, who helped us with translation this week, and to producer Ellen Paine Smith, who juggled multiple microphones to help us interview the Waygood family.
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、克里斯·巴鲁贝、拉舍马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢本周帮助我们翻译的惠美·山本，以及在采访韦古德一家时处理多个麦克风的制片人艾伦·佩恩·史密斯。
Thanks also to Rebecca Clements, who turned reporter Henry Cabar, onto my first errand. You can find the link to Henry's original story about the show and slate on our website. Also, Henry has a new book coming out next year called Paved Paradise, How Parking Explains the World. I mean, if you can't tell from that title,
还要感谢丽贝卡·克莱门茨，她把记者亨利·克拉巴介绍给了《初次跑腿》。你可以在我们的网站上找到亨利关于这个节目和Slate的原始故事的链接。此外，亨利明年有一本新书要出版，叫《铺好的天堂，停车如何解释世界》。我的意思是，如果从那个标题看不出来，
you don't know me very well, but I am very much looking forward to this book. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
你不太了解我，但我非常期待这本书。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. I'm going to use the same method as the other one. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，以及该节目@99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。你可以找到其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一集过往节目，网址是99PI.org。我将使用与另一个相同的方法。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。